based on a true story is the oldest
trick in Hollywood's book and horror
fans have seen variations on that idea
countless times the blurry or the line
between fact and fiction the bigger the
potential scares right but sometimes the
stories behind the scenes are even more
terrifying here's some horror movies
based on even scarier true stories
Dracula
Bram Stoker's classic story has been
revisited countless times in cinema
making it some of the most beloved
source material of all time but until
Francis Ford Coppola 's 1992 film Bram
Stoker's Dracula the connection between
Dracula and historical figure vlad Drac
had never been depicted on screen if you
think a pale immortal vampire poised to
suck your blood is scary consider Vlad
the Impaler
a Transylvanian noble is thought to have
tortured and executed as many as a
hundred thousand peasants and civilians
during his reign deeming the poor is
useless to society he had them slowly
impaled from bottom to top and then
hoisted publicly for display so which is
scarier the Fang or the pole The
Exorcist the oscar-winning 1973 film The
Exorcist was based on the 1949 position
of a Maryland boy named Roland doe who
reportedly underwent an exhausting
battery of exorcism performed by Jesuit
priests while skeptics maintain the
dough was insane the phenomenon of
demonic possession has been traced at
biblical times and is taken very
seriously by religious experts while
neither spinning heads nor projectile
vomit has been wildly reported
levitations shaking beds and speaking in
tongues have not scared yet well
consider that the demand for exorcisms
has rapidly increased in recent years in
2015 the Catholic Church reported having
as many as a hundred requests at any
given time The Amityville Horror the
house at 112 Ocean Avenue in Amityville
Long Island is an icon of the horror
genre having inspired the Amityville
horror film franchise but what
transpired at the actual address is more
horrific than anything to take it in a
franchise they are 24 year-old Ron de
feo brutally murdered his mother father
and four younger siblings with a shotgun
in 1974 the hotly contested account in
Jansen's book details the bizarre events
that followed the house reportedly stood
empty for 13 months until the Lutz
family moved in only to abruptly flee
after 28 days claiming they had been
terrorized by paranormal phenomena after
extensive paranormal investigations for
decades subsequent owners remodeled the
exterior and
no longer even listed as 112 Ocean
Avenue the house is still standing
though and for just a low low price of
eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars
it too can be yours the Serpent and the
rainbow zombies are all the rage as The
Walking Dead and privately every other
TV show and video games seem to prove in
Wes Craven's 1988 voodoo horror film the
serpent in the rainbow however we find a
very different kind of zombie it's
loosely adapted from a nonfiction book
of the same name by ethnobotany suede
Davis who outlined his expeditions to
Haiti investigating the bizarre case of
clairvius narcisse
a man who had reportedly returned from
the dead according to Narcisse he was
administered a puffer fish toxin after
offending a voodoo sorcerer as a result
he collapsed and was pronounced dead but
he was actually conscious during the
delivery of his death certificate and
witnessed his own burial from inside the
casket he was recovered from his grave
two days after his funeral and was
enslaved forced to work on a sugar
plantation Narcisse was finally released
and returned to his village 18 years
later where the dead man reunited with
his sister so happy ending kinda a
terrifying
Ed Gein some of the scariest and
best-known characters in horror have
been based on the serial killer at gain
Dean's grisly murder spree inspired
Leatherface of the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre Norman Bates of psycho and
Buffalo Bill of The Silence of the Lambs
just to name a few
in fact Dean's actual crimes were so
heinous that he might be the most
monstrous figure in American history
beguin family wasn't exactly a Norman
Rockwell portrait to begin with his
father and two brothers passed away
early in his life after the passing of
his sole companion his beloved mother
ian lived alone in their rural Wisconsin
farmhouse the mild-mannered handyman
didn't attract much attention to 12
years following her death but when a
neighboring a hardware store owner
disappeared in 1957 ian came under
suspicion and a search of his property
revealed the decapitated woman in a shed
splayed out like a free skinned deer
inside the house authorities found masks
wastebaskets and lampshades made from
human skin along with assorted human
remains in fact some of what was
discovered as far too grisly to mention
here but suffice it to say genes living
room would make leather face plush it
was later determined that he'd also been
making late-night visits to nearby
cemeteries exhuming women who looked
like his mother
this room was found boarded up and
completely untouched Ian's story even
sans chainsaw is truly the stuff of
nightmares thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch
less scary videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which of these true stories is
scarier than fiction
[Music]